hola buenas tardes bienvenidos a todos
me da mucho gusto estar esta tarde con
ustedes mi nombre es
para ti garcía y la capacitación de hoy
va a ser acerca de las diferentes
estrategias que podemos utilizar para
motivar a nuestros alumnos bienvenido
el tanto el leaks tapalapa desde el
conalep de tea calco también la scala
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
bienvenidos es muy importante que
participen en esta en esta capacitación
en este entrenamiento así que quiero
invitarles a que a través del chat nos
hagan llegar sus sugerencias sus
comentarios sus experiencias porque en
la medida en que ustedes participen y
nos compartan también
sus ideas etcétera podemos enriquecer
aún más este entrenamiento
muchas gracias por venir gracias de
verdad por su apoyo por su compromiso y
bueno nosotros queremos reiterarles a
una y otra vez digamos que aquí estamos
para cualquier necesidad que tengan de
manera que puedan ustedes maximizar los
resultados académicos de todos sus
alumnos en sus diferentes planteles
plantel de guadalajara bienvenido a poza
rica
irapuato honduras muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos por estar aquí presentes
quiero compartirles el enlace de esta
capacitación de esta presentación y si
tiene su dispositivo a la mano abran una
ventana y una vez pueden bajarlo
guardarlo en su dispositivo este lo
pueden utilizar más adelante no se
quieren recurrir a él y para referencias
posteriores si no tienen su dispositivo
yo lo que les sugiero es que le tomen
una foto al enlace para que más adelante
puedan ya bajarlo a su computador
jeje punto jeje diagonal
d minúscula t de tomás minúscula 4 c de
casa minúscula y b de bb minúscula
les voy a dar unos segundos para que
puedan ingresar y abrir la presentación
buena tarde ni sábana y salinas
bienvenida
nuevamente los invitamos a que participe
en la que nos escriban nos envíen sus
sugerencias sus ideas sus experiencias
de verdad que es muy importante para
nosotros y vamos a comenzar bueno
creo que es muy importante en cualquier
proyecto que estamos iniciando
y desarrollar un plan o un plan
estratégico para motivarnos o para
motivar a nuestros alumnos y en este
caso ahorita que estamos participando en
el campeonato es muy importante tener un
plan no en donde tengamos nosotros
claros como muy claro como planeamos
seguir el progreso de nuestros alumnos
cómo vamos a celebrar sus logros cómo
vamos a reconocernos su esfuerzo la
energía que están poniendo en cumplir
sus objetivos cómo podemos motivarlos no
para que sigan perseverando para que
puedan orientarse hacia el éxito no
hacia la excelencia y cómo vamos a
evaluar el desempeño y el esfuerzo de
nuestros alumnos en la plataforma de
khan academy
y quiero compartirles con ustedes este
pequeño vídeo voy primero a traducirlo
van a ponerle subtítulos al español para
que todos lo podamos entender mejor este
vídeo a mí me encanta porque realmente
me parece muy significativo
tenemos unos segunditos y estamos listos
e incluso tiene aquí uno
ok comenzamos
[Música]
nombres bots
mira oscar el libro
[Música]
[Aplausos]
marín marín a pain
[Música]
sí
o no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
son
y no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
aunque como sea como dice el vídeo no a
mí me parece un vídeo verdaderamente
interesante porque concuerdo con este
vídeo no de que podemos aprender lo que
sea cuando sea no estamos siempre
nosotros aprendiendo constantemente
entonces esta idea de que podemos
aprender lo que sea cuando sea y en
donde sea es muy importante que nuestros
alumnos entiendan esto lo que realmente
promoverles esa mentalidad de
aprendizaje de que se aprende no
solamente dentro del salón de clases
sino también afuera del salón de clases
y bueno sabemos que hay diferentes tipos
de motivaciones no tenemos esta
motivación intrínseca no que es la la
motivación que viene desde dentro no
desde parte del mismo alumno y es una
motivación un tipo de motivación muy
importante porque realmente el alumno
que se siente motivado ya per se
realmente no necesita no del
reconocimiento externo porque ya él
mismo está motivando se al éxito no
entonces es una manera muy importante de
motivarnos y hay diferentes formas de
poder lograr esto no como como lo
podemos hacer yo creo que cuando el
alumno tiene una sensación un poco de
control dentro del salón de clases que
quiero decir con esto no que el alumno
puede sentir lo que tiene el control
sobre qué es lo que necesita aprender
cuando lo necesita aprender no todos
nuestros alumnos tienen las mismas
capacidades ni tienen tampoco las mismas
habilidades desarrolla
etcétera entonces cuando un alumno es
capaz de tomar sus propias decisiones de
qué es lo que necesita practicar de que
en que se necesita enfocar etcétera
automáticamente se siente más motivado
no y esto es darles un poquito el
control de su propio aprendizaje que el
alumno sienta lo que es responsable de
su propio aprendizaje también yo creo
que es muy importante crear un entorno
libre de amenazas en donde el alumno se
sienta con la confianza de poder
expresar sus dudas expresar sus a sus
frustraciones etc
sabemos además como maestros de
matemáticas y de ciencias que nuestras
materias en general resultan a veces
complicadas no para para muchos de
nuestros alumnos entonces entran ya
nuestros salones de clase ya con no con
un sentido y con un sentimiento digamos
de fracaso de frustración etcétera no y
luego llegan a estos salones de clase en
donde no se siente con la confianza
preguntar por qué se sienten intimidados
por qué se sienten expuestos entonces si
nosotros como profesores generamos un
ambiente en donde el alumno se sienta
confiado es automáticamente auto perdón
auto automáticamente lo va a hacer
sentirse motivado no para poder
participar en clase o yo creo que otra
forma de motivar también a los alumnos
dentro de nuestro salón de clases
promoviendo una competencia positiva una
competencia sana ya sea entre alumnos ya
sea con otros grupos siempre destacando
sus habilidades siempre destacando sus
esfuerzos pero también estas
competencias siempre los estimulan a
todos no todos tenemos este sentimiento
de competitivo no unos más desarrollados
que otros pero siempre te llevan a
esforzarte más entonces cuando nosotros
promovemos este tipo de competencia
automáticamente el ambiente en el salón
de clases también cambian
promover el aprendizaje activo es otra
manera también de motivar al alumno
cuando nosotros le damos al alumno voz
cuando le damos al alumno la capacidad
de expresarse en la capacidad de actuar
dentro del salón de clase de estar
activo también en el ambiente del salón
cambiamos a hoy día
y las habilidades que tenemos que
nosotros como docentes desarrollar
nuestros alumnos son muy variadas no
estamos desarrollando y educando a los
alumnos del siglo 21 que están
enfrentándose a retos insospechados no
porque la educación la tecnología todo
está cambiando a una velocidad enorme
entonces nosotros como docentes tenemos
que estar conscientes de que estamos hoy
día educando a alumnos que el día de
mañana en un par de años en unos tres
años seis años cinco años que salgan no
a la universidad etcétera o a seguir
estudiando a estar trabajando van a
trabajar y van a estudiar profesiones
que a lo mejor hoy día no existen no
entonces nosotros tenemos que dotarlos
de habilidades que se van desarrollando
dentro del salón de clases no
habilidades como el pensamiento crítico
habilidades como la colaboración la
comunicación todo esto dentro del salón
de clases no promoviendo el desarrollo
de estas habilidades por ejemplo a
través también del trabajo colaborativo
lo importante que es que los alumnos
aprenden aprendan a trabajar junto con
otros no a poder colaborar a poder
comunicarse yo creo que hoy son
habilidades indispensables que pueden
llevar a nuestros alumnos al éxito
buenas tardes a todos los que se siguen
uniendo
con la ley para tizapán no les doy la
bienvenida y bueno vamos a ir
resolviendo algunas de las dudas que
tienen aquí si tienen 12 años si tienen
no aquí necesitamos que tengan 18 años o
más para participar en estos webinars
y bueno vamos a hablar ahora otra manera
de poder motivar a nuestros alumnos es
estableciendo objetivos claros es súper
importante que nuestros alumnos tengan
muy claras nuestras expectativas no en
la medida que nosotros tengamos
objetivos claros y se nos planteamos
desde un principio a nuestros alumnos
ellos saben perfectamente bien van
entender perfectamente bien qué es lo
que esperamos de ellos de esta manera
pueden trabajar no enfocados en el logro
de estos objetivos pero cuando no los
tienen claros es muy difícil es
definitivamente muy difícil para ellos
poder alcanzarlos no entonces ahí es
cuando pues se genera la frustración se
genera la desmotivación etcétera no
entonces
los invito a que tengamos objetivos
claros no que tengamos
claro hacia dónde queremos que nuestros
alumnos lleguen lo que ellos necesitan
saber no entender bien que esperamos de
ellos para mantenerse motivados para
trabajar entonces de principio de año
establezcamos objetivos claros reglas y
expectativas para que no haya confusión
para que no haya sorpresas y los
estudiantes puedan tener sus metas
claras no para trabajar de una mejor
manera
cuando nosotros establecemos objetivos
claros los alumnos se sienten motivados
para y además forman parte sienten que
forman parte de una comunidad y empiezan
a trabajar de manera conjunta por el
logro de un objetivo en común no y esto
es muy importante también establecer
objetivos grupales e individuales que
sean cuantificables ambiciosos pero
sobre todo realistas esta parte es muy
importante porque si nosotros generamos
a objetivos no solamente que no sean
claros sino que son inalcanzables pues
definitivamente vamos a generar un
sentimiento de frustración en nuestros
alumnos entonces esto es precisamente lo
que no queremos entonces hagamos algo
que sean a que sea alcanzable para los
alumnos no además nuestros alumnos no
son iguales entonces probablemente
tengamos también que adaptarnos a los
objetivos individuales de cada alumno
y a la vez implementar un programa de
recompensas de incentivos para poder
reconocer el logro de nuestros alumnos
cuáles son algunas maneras no para poder
reconocer o para poder motivar de manera
extra y seca a nuestros alumnos bueno a
todos nos gusta no a grandes y chicos
recibir recompensas y el hecho de
ofrecer a nuestros estudiantes la
oportunidad de ganarlos es una excelente
fuente de motivación no algunas eventos
como fiestas con pizza o ver una
película regalarles un sticker este
traerles donas no sé no ellos porque
cada quien va conociendo a sus alumnos y
de la manga en la manera en que los
conocemos podemos también definir no
cuáles son esas recompensas que podemos
darles
entonces considerando las personalidades
y las necesidades de nuestros
estudiantes podemos determinar de una
mejor manera qué es lo mejor para
nuestra clase no entonces podemos
recompensar a nuestros alumnos con un
certificado personalizado por ejemplo
el cual podemos a lo mejor entregar
dentro del salón de clases
el viernes el último día de la semana no
con un aplauso con un reconocimiento con
no llamar su no ya llamarlos por su
nombre o bien en una ceremonia semanal
no que si ustedes tienen una ceremonia
no sé de la bandera una vez a la semana
en el plantel pues llamar a esos alumnos
y enfrente de todos sus compañeros
reconocer ese esfuerzo y es la verdad un
pequeño detalle sin embargo para ellos
llega a significar muchísimo entonces es
muy importante personalizarlo no con
solo hombre una descripción de por qué
está recibiendo este certificado
etcétera otra manera de poder reconocer
sus logros y motivar motivarlos está lo
mejor colocando un tablero de anuncios
para celebrar sus avances no podemos
escoger qué es lo que queremos celebrar
no quizá el número de tareas completadas
quizá el número de vídeos vistos las
medallas que han ganado
no quien ha practicado más habilidades
dentro de la plataforma en determinado
tiempo como les comentaba las medallas
que han ganado sabemos que para
campeonato los que ya estamos
registrados en campeonato y estamos
participando ya en campeonato sabemos
que el requisito es cumplir con tres
recursos o tres asignaciones por semana
no entonces aquellos alumnos que
terminan sus asignaciones sus tres
asignaciones lo más rápido de premiar a
los primeros diez reconocer a los
primeros diez que las terminan etcétera
no podemos hacer a celebrar diferentes
cosas entonces con que pongan un tablero
en su salón de clases y no se hagan
medallas de papel y poder ponerle el
nombre del alumno y reconociendo los
logros esto es una manera muy visual no
y muy económica de reconocernos no y los
alumnos se sienten muy motivados de ver
su nombre plasmado en no en este
pizarrón
otra manera es organizando a la mejor
una fiesta con pizza a una fiesta con
donas con helado no o ponerles una
película si logran el objetivo común
etcétera yo creo que esta parte también
es es muy importante en esta parte los
alumnos se sientan reconocidos los
alumnos se sienten conectados con el
profesor yo creo que esta parte de
motivar
es súper importante porque los alumnos
se genera una conexión con él con el
maestro cuando tenemos y trabajamos en
conjunto no por uno por objetivos
comunes de definitivamente la relación
que se crea entre maestro y alumnos es
muy importante y muy fuerte es por eso
que a mí el programa este de campeonato
me encanta porque si considero que es
una manera no empezamos el año con el
pie derecho no con una con una actitud
súper positiva trabajando en conjunto
etcétera entonces me parece algo
indispensable no para el inicio de del
año
vamos a hacer un paréntesis para ver si
tenemos preguntas o comentarios
bienvenido pueblo
este vídeo puede ser consultado en negro
booker si está la está en la
presentación el vídeo que les pase está
en la presentación ustedes pueden tener
acceso a este vídeo
ahí está el enlace dentro de la
presentación
les voy a agradecer muchísimo que
compartan con nosotros cuáles son las
estrategias que ustedes están utilizando
para motivar a sus alumnos para no parar
en celebrar sus logros etcétera yo creo
que nuevamente en la medida que ustedes
compartan cuáles son sus estrategias nos
podemos enriquecer todos no porque todos
podemos aprender de todos
aquí nos dice el profesor también que
dice decirles que lo que van a aprender
parece difícil pero es muy fácil cambia
la química cerebral y los dispone a
aprender totalmente de acuerdo y vamos a
hablar mucho de esto más adelante
el profesor geo primera mes y me sucedió
algo curioso los grupos en cuanto
supieron que están en el campeonato
disminuyeron su participación a que se
pudo deber quizás no tengan los
objetivos claros quizá les falta un
poquito entender de qué se trata
campeonato es importante que dentro del
campeonato ellos revisen no lo que viene
siendo el tablero de progreso porque el
tablero de progreso va reconociendo a
los alumnos les va dando premios
digitales no entonces yo creo que
también en la medida que usted profesor
comparta a lo mejor en redes sociales
los éxitos de sus alumnos los logros de
sus alumnos una foto no de un vídeo de
ellos no se celebrando su éxito todo
esto los va motivando a no a engancharse
más no con la plataforma con el proyecto
ya realmente participar de una mejor
manera
desde guadalajara bienvenidos profesora
lourdes hernández y bueno vamos a
continuar otra manera de motivar a
nuestros alumnos puede ser a través de
un desafío semanal o mensual no especie
como dec al curso en donde podemos
pensar en cómo lo comentábamos hace rato
en promover una competencia sana no ya
sea entre nuestros alumnos ya sea con
otras clases para ver quién va llegando
más lejos quién va terminando primero
sus actividades nos recuerden que para
campeonato es requisito no asignar al
menos tres recursos ya sean vídeos ya
sean ejercicios ya sean artículos pero
al menos tres recursos por semana a
todos nuestros alumnos recuerden que
para que nuestro grupo tenga éxito los
alumnos deben participar al 100% lo que
quiere decir esto que si yo tengo 20
alumnos y asignó 3 actividades a cada
uno de mis alumnos al final para
alcanzar el 100% campeonato tengo que
tener reportadas 60 actividades es por
eso que hay que motivar a todos nuestros
alumnos no qué podemos hacer por ejemplo
otra manera podría hacer que a los
primeros 10 alumnos que terminen sus 3
recursos asignados les podemos dar un
boleto y al final del mes o al final de
equis número de semana no pueden
intercambiar esos boletos por un sticker
por un lápiz etcétera recuerden que
también
en acceso a un kit de khan academy que
está diseñado para justamente para este
programa entonces pueden darle algún
lápiz algún premio a los alumnos que van
cumpliendo con los objetivos y al final
de cada semana reconocer este esfuerzo
no y celebrar sus logros entonces es muy
importante hacer esto para que ellos
vayan motivando seno y cuando los
alumnos entienden que además el éxito
del grupo depende también en parte de
ellos ellos debo finalmente terminan
sumándose al objetivo común otra manera
de de motivar a los alumnos y esta parte
a mí me encanta porque es haciéndolos
responsables de su propio avance
haciéndolos responsables de su propio
aprendizaje si nosotros por ejemplo
creamos en un póster no podemos hacer
tres o cuatro o cinco diferentes posters
en donde nosotros
y nos pongamos alguna alguna cualidad
alguna habilidad algo que los alumnos
están logrando por ejemplo un póster que
diga perseverancia otro póster que diga
medallas de agujero negro medallas lunas
medallas solé cetera entonces que los
alumnos puedan tener esa libertad de
levantarse de su escritorio y ir a notar
ellos mismos su nombre en algunos de
estos postres porque fui perseverante
porque ya me gané la medalla luna porque
ya pude obtener la medalla sol ya medida
que ellos mismos van ganando medallas y
van trabajando por su objetivo propio
individual y común ellos tengan esa
libertad no de de levantarse y de ir a
notar su propio nombre en estos postres
no donde van a ser reconocidos entonces
ésta se basa una manera muy linda de
reconocer su esfuerzo porque nuevamente
les estamos dando a ellos la posibilidad
de reconocerse a sí mismo que a veces
tan difícil no reconocer nuestros logros
nuestro compromiso nuestro esfuerzo a
veces nos cuesta entonces esta es una
manera muy buena de decirle al alumno te
hago responsable no sólo de tu
aprendizaje pero también de tu propio
reconocimiento
otra manera importantísima que se me
hace una excelente manera de promover la
motivación entre los alumnos es
fomentando la asesoría entre ellos
mismos un alumno siempre se va a sentir
ha motivado digamos si tiene la
posibilidad de ayudar a sus compañeros
tenemos alumnos y todos y todos a
nuestros salones de clases lo tenemos
que son muy buenos en matemáticas que
siempre van un paso más adelante que
entienden todo muy bien que lo tienen
muy claro y tenemos también otros
alumnos que tienen un poquito más de
problemas en entender ciertos conceptos
no entonces por qué no promover que se
ayuden mutuamente al final ellos hablan
el mismo lenguaje y muchas veces
entienden mejor la explicación de su
compañero que la explicación de nosotros
como docentes no porque se entienden
porque hablan el mismo idioma por alguna
razón en especial no entonces una
sugerencia que les puedo dar es que
coloquen al alumno con una cartulina
dentro de su salón de clases
dibujen tres columnas en una la primera
columna se va a notar aquel alumno que
necesita ayuda que está buscando ayuda
en la segunda columna va ese alumno va a
anotar en qué concepto veces está
buscando ayuda o necesita ayuda y en la
tercera columna se va a notar el alumno
que puede ayudarlo no en esa en
estabilidad por ejemplo en la primera
columna se puede podemos tener no sé no
a maría gonzález en la segunda columna
va a notar ya tengo problemas con orden
de operaciones y en la tercera columna
susana garcía le va a decir yo te puedo
ayudarlo entonces ya ni nosotros
necesitamos involucrarnos entre
involucrarnos no entre ellos se ponen de
acuerdo entre ellos o que ofrecen ayuda
y entre ellos puedan encontrar el punto
para buscar un espacio en donde el
compañero pueda explicarle el habilidad
o no el concepto que no está entendiendo
una carita feliz y el líder nos comenta
que una cara una carita feliz al
calificar una calcomanía una estrellita
hace diferencias de verdad que es cierto
no otras detalles tan pequeños hacen la
diferencia no un excelente un bien hecho
todo eso definitivamente
motiva a los alumnos no les saca una
sonrisa los motiva a seguir poniendo
todo su esfuerzo
tenemos también aquí tenemos pueblo a
pueblo presente muchas gracias por estar
aquí se pone un grupo ya van en el nivel
6 con 40 alumnos felicidades esto es un
gran logro esto es maravilloso y
nuevamente de verdad que queremos
escuchar de estas historias estas son
historias de éxito ya existen
digo varios vídeos tanto en eeuu como en
otros países latinos como brasil
etcétera en donde los alumnos están
celebrando sus logros donde hay fotos en
donde hay testimonios no sobre estos
casos de éxito pero en méxico
necesitamos necesitamos publicar estos
mensajes no necesitamos ir también
acumulando nuestros testimonios así que
queremos invitarlos a que a que los
publiquen ya sea en twitter en en
facebook
tomen una foto tomen un vídeo tomen una
foto es el tablero de progreso con el
nivel 6 que es algo no pues algo que
celebrar y publiquen lo pongan la foto
ponga su nombre diga
mi grupo llegó al nivel 6 siempre con el
hashtag campeonato o campeonato 2018
pero esa es otra manera de motivar a
nuestros alumnos no solamente
reconociendo los dentro de nuestro
plantel o de nuestro salón de clases
sino saliendo al exterior no utilizando
las redes sociales en particular a mí
tanto twitter como facebook ciones en
redes excelentes excelentes para nuestra
actividad como docentes porque realmente
podemos hacer comunidad con muchos otros
maestros y compartir experiencias
sugerencias y consejos etcétera no
entonces de verdad que los invito no a
que a que promuevan el trabajo de sus
alumnos a que compartan no cuáles son
sus éxitos etcétera no trinidad puebla
en el plantel de acá algo se ha
realizado concurso de su trabajo en la
plataforma se premia los tres primeros
lugares
perfecto excelente un usb un balón de
fútbol y con esto los alumnos se motivan
y trabajan fuerte excelente consejo de
helen excelente sugerencia todos los
planteles tendrán no diferentes formas
de celebrar de reconocer a sus alumnos
pero no importa la manera digo porque
hay muchísimas maneras pero lo
importante es que lo hagamos lo que
encontramos encontremos la mejor manera
que se adapte a nuestra personalidad ya
la personalidad de nuestros estudiantes
pero definitivamente hacerlo otra manera
de motivar a nuestros alumnos es a
través de las actividades de mentalidad
de crecimiento
estas actividades bueno khan academy las
ha diseñado en conjunto con pérez que es
un centro de investigación de la
universidad de stanford y la el objetivo
de estas actividades es ayudar a los
educadores a aplicar
estrategias basadas no solamente en
evidencias sino también en estudios de
manera que los alumnos puedan alcanzar
la excelencia académica y la equidad nos
comenta lourdes hernández hoy nombre en
clase a un estudiante dije quién es y
como asustado me dijo bueno es que lo vi
y se le dieron un aplauso porque lleva
la mejor puntuación en caracas
finalmente sergio porque creyó que lo
iban a regañar eso es quiso pasan ahora
los alumnos a veces ya están un poco con
él con el prejuicio de que cuando
nosotros los vamos a llamar los vamos a
les vamos a pedir que se levanten lo que
me venga a ver el setter allá ya está en
el instituto de que que hice mal no y
hay que cambiar este chip a nuestros
alumnos hay que promover la confianza en
ellos no y yo creo que la medida en que
reconocemos sus logros porque a veces no
están acostumbrados a que nosotros
reconozcamos sus logros y es por eso que
perdón a veces se sienten
espantado se sienten como que un poco
fuera del lugar cuando los llamamos
porque disculpen como como docentes no
estamos a veces acostumbrados a
reconocerlos y menos en público no
entonces felicidades a la maestra por
haber hecho esto porque yo creo que
estoy segura que es alumno seguirá
trabajando con muchas más ganas y bueno
las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento definitivamente ayudan a los
alumnos a que cambien este chip no de
esta mentalidad de frustración de
fracaso por una mentalidad de éxito no
sé si ustedes ya las están asignando
recuerden que un campeonato es también
obligación no es requerimiento básico
asignar este tipo de actividades junto
con las tres actividades académicas que
debemos asignar recuerden que las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
no son actividades de matemáticas ni de
ciencias ni nada por el estilo son
actividades que están hechas y diseñadas
para que el alumno vaya aprendiendo a
conocerse
cómo funciona su cerebro a ir
desarrollando estrategias de aprendizaje
etcétera entonces se enfocan en muchas
habilidades que benefician a los alumnos
en su proceso de aprendizaje como les
comentaba estas actividades fueron
diseñadas en prex que es el centro de
estudios de stanford a partir de unas
investigaciones hechas por la doctora
carol dweck y esto es lo que promueve es
una mentalidad de crecimiento versó es
una mentalidad fija muchos de nuestros
alumnos de verdad entran a nuestras
materias los generales de matemáticas y
ciencias ya con esta mentalidad de
fracaso ya con esta mentalidad de no es
que yo no nací para esto yo no crecí
no yo no entro no soy buena en esto yo
no crecí así yo no tengo cerebro para
matemáticas y ya de entrada tienen está
esta mentalidad de yo no puedo de esto
no se me da entonces es trabajar con
ellos para que aprendan que estas
habilidades se desarrollan que todo lo
que ellos quieran aprender
lo pueden aprender a través del esfuerzo
de la resiliencia de no de la
perseverancia entonces que ellos
entiendan que los errores son
oportunidades de aprendizaje
desgraciadamente en nuestra cultura nos
han enseñado que el fracaso no está
permitido el fracaso lo vemos como algo
malo no el fracaso realmente tiene una
connotación super negativa en nuestra
cultura sin embargo debemos a enseñar a
nuestros alumnos o promover la idea de
que los errores y el frank los fracasos
son oportunidades de aprendizaje son
solamente un paso más para lograr el
éxito y estas actividades lo que hacen
es
dar esa fortaleza a los alumnos para que
vayan superando la frustración vayan
desarrollando estrategias para que
aprendan mejor van creando metas
individuales y mente y van
mentalizándose para el éxito no tenemos
actividades que son dirigidas
especialmente para bachillerato y otras
actividades dirigidas especialmente para
primaria y secundaria
entonces que incluyen estas actividades
estas actividades incluyen desde vídeos
para explicar cómo funciona el cerebro y
otros artículos sobre la importancia de
importante de imponernos metas no
entonces incluye testimonios también de
otros alumnos entonces es muy importante
que a la par de que asignemos nuestros
tres recursos académicos así vayamos
asignando también estas actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento
lourdes hernández s no me da la opción
de seleccionar la mentalidad de
crecimiento auris te voy a entrar yo a
la plataforma para enseñarles
directamente como las podemos encontrar
y cómo las podemos asignar y me comenta
ross a la profesora arroz si les gustan
los ejercicios y van reforzando sus
conocimientos
muchas gracias muchísimas gracias por
sus comentarios sigan haciéndonos llegar
por favor sus sugerencias sus
experiencias
ok cuál es realmente la diferencia entre
una mentalidad de crecimiento y una
mentalidad fría fija la mentalidad de
crecimiento es la creencia de que tú
puedes
hacer que tú quieres que tu cerebro
crezca no que tu inteligencia se
desarrolle que vaya creciendo a medida
que tú te vas esforzando y vas
trabajando con las estrategias adecuadas
no para tu forma de aprender una
mentalidad de crecimiento se centra en
el proceso de aprendizaje no en el
resultado
a diferencia de una mentalidad fija que
es la creencia de que lo hacen así no
este es esto así es mi cerebro este es
no mi capacidad yo no nací para esto a
mí esto no se me da
yo no tengo cerebro para las matemáticas
ya no tengo cerebro para las ciencias y
se van centrando en el resultado no y
para la mentalidad fija sólo existen dos
resultados el éxito o el fracaso
entonces esto es con lo que tenemos que
luchar con lo que tenemos que trabajar
no algunas ideas erróneas sobre la
mentalidad de crecimiento nuevamente no
es el tener una mentalidad fija una
mentalidad de hacinas y así soy es muy
difícil que yo cambie no como porque
piensan que es por genética no yo nací
con x neuronas con x capacidad no con x
inteligencia y no puedo hacer más y esto
definitivamente no es cierto no a medida
que uno trabaja duro que te pones metas
altas no que tienes resiliencia que
tienes ideas
claras ya sé a dónde quieres llegar en
esa medida vamos a lograr las metas en
uno de los webinars que di en la mañana
sobre este tema
un profesor comentó que me encantó
desear motivarlos a que cumplan sus
sueños y yo creo que esta parte es muy
importante no y cómo podemos motivarlos
a que nuestros alumnos alcancen sus
sueños es cambiándoles esta mentalidad
cambiando esa mentalidad fija de que no
pueden de que no pueden lograrlo de que
tienen limitaciones por una mentalidad
de crecimiento porque una vez que el
alumno cambia su chip de una mentalidad
fija a una mentalidad de crecimiento
cualquier cosa que se proponga cualquier
sueño que tenga lo puede lograr no
porque teniendo esa mentalidad de
crecimiento realmente puede aprender lo
que sea no
y simplemente necesita poner su máximo
esfuerzo no podemos promover la
mentalidad de crecimiento premiando los
estudiantes cuando luchan por entender
algo como como lo estamos como veo que
lo estamos haciendo ya no lo hacemos
diariamente como comentaban aquí a
través de una estampilla a través de una
carita feliz a través de un certificado
a través de un balón de fútbol
simplemente reconocerlos en las
diferentes maneras y con eso estamos
reconociendo su esfuerzo y su logro y
también a otra parte importante de la
que podemos hacer para motivar a los
alumnos y para enseñarles que la
mentalidad de crecimiento existe es
compartir con ellos nuestras propias
experiencias nosotros como docentes
hemos tenido en el fracasos también
hemos tenido también a situaciones no en
donde en donde a lo mejor no hemos
tenido éxito a la primera pero
trabajando y perseverando hemos seguido
ha llegado a tener éxito en nosotros en
la medida que ustedes también compartan
sus propias experiencias de vida
con los alumnos esto de verdad nos va a
motivar mucho no yo siempre les cuento a
mis alumnos que cuando yo estaba en
primaria no me gustaban nada las
matemáticas por lo mismo porque sentía
que era mala porque sentía que no tenía
la capacidad porque no las entendía
etcétera no y en secundaria tuve un
maestro maravilloso que bueno me abrió
el cielo y en fin no fue mi sol porque
él me iluminó no y finalmente acabe no
sólo entendiendo matemáticas sino me
encantaron las matemáticas al grado que
llegué a estudiar química ciencias no y
realmente me permitió dedicarme a la
profesión que yo quería y terminé dando
clases de matemáticas no entonces como
es importante compartir estas
experiencias con los alumnos porque la
medida que nos ver a nosotros también
como como personas no con con
frustraciones con fracasos etcétera
ellos pueden identificarse con nosotros
no y seguir trabajando por su propio
éxito
entonces qué debemos hacer para promover
la mentalidad de crecimiento de nuestros
alumnos
y asignar las actividades semanales de
mentalidad de crecimiento que se
encuentran en sus clases vamos a ver
ahorita cómo podemos asignar las y
compartiendo como les comenté ahorita su
propia experiencia de éxito de fracasos
de perseverancia etcétera eso es esa
parte de verdad los va a conectar
muchísimo con sus alumnos con el
contenido de la mentalidad de
crecimiento como les comentaba tenemos
actividades que van dirigidas
especialmente para la primaria y
secundaria y actividades especialmente
para bachillerato no y cómo vamos a
asignar o dónde encontramos estas
actividades para poder explicarles esta
parte me voy a salir de la presentación
y voy a entrar a la plataforma entonces
una vez que yo estoy en plataforma
recuerden a voy a entrar aquí o iniciar
sesión
ok
ok una vez que entro yo voy a entrar a
la clase a la que quiero asignarle
digamos la
las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento entonces recuerden por lo
primero que nada ya empezó el campeonato
si alguno de ustedes maestros no se ha
registrado hay tiempo todavía saben los
registros no se han cerrado recuerden
que para participar el único requisito
es que su clase tenga 10 alumnos o más y
registrarse ya eliminen sus clases
viejas que tienen que crear sus clases
nuevas invitadas sus alumnos y
registrarse y todas las clases que
ustedes tengan abiertas con un cambio
con cada academia automáticamente van a
quedar registradas en campeonato
entonces todavía hay tiempo apenas está
comenzando y la verdad es una manera de
comenzar el año escolar con el pie
derecho porque automáticamente estamos
motivando a nuestros alumnos a trabajar
en equipo y no por un logro en común
entonces los invito a que si no se han
registrado se registren ya
ahora vamos a ver aquí
vamos a ver con algunas de las clases
que yo tengo y bueno más fuera yo tengo
esta clase en donde el contenido que yo
seleccione es de segundo de secundaria
es segundo de secundaria y pre algebra
recuerden ustedes que yo siempre puedo
evitar mis cursos ya sea agregar o
quitar ya sea a través aquí de contenido
o bien en configuración si yo me voy a
configuración aquí también en curso
también puedo cambiar el curso o
nuevamente desde contenido aquí dice
segundo secundaria la flechita abajo ya
que me dice yo aquí tengo asignado dos
cursos para esta clase y voy a hacer
clic en editar cursos automáticamente se
me abren todas las opciones no te de los
cursos que yo puedo asignar en mi
plataforma de español entonces
recuerden que puedo asignar más de un
curso como les digo en este ejemplo
tengo pre álgebra y segundo de
secundaria asignado para esta clase
también puedo asignar geometría etcétera
si yo me desplazo en este mismo
en esta misma ventana hacia abajo aquí
encuentro mentalidad de crecimiento
entonces yo aquí voy a hacer clic en
mentalidad de crecimiento y voy a decir
guardar
automáticamente al hacer yo clic
nuevamente en contenido y hago clic aquí
aquí ya me va a aparecer mentalidad de
crecimiento que tengo que hacer ahora
hacer clic en mentalidad de crecimiento
y entonces me me abren las opciones de
mentalidad de crecimiento me dice ok
quieres la introducción del contenido de
mentalidad de crecimiento está unidad va
mucho muy dirigida a nosotros como
docentes no cuáles son los planes de
clase
porque la importancia digamos de
mentalidad de crecimiento cuáles son
algunos consejos de los expertos que
diseñaron estas actividades para los
profesores
la visión general etcétera si yo me voy
para abajo aquí código actividades de
primaria y secundaria hago clic y
comienzo a ver las actividades y las
asignamos al igual que asignamos
cualquier otro contenido académico yo
veo actividad 1 abro son tres
actividades entonces yo al al ver la
actividad digamos osa veo la actividad y
una vez que yo estoy viendo la actividad
etcétera
yo la seleccionó selecciona que las
actividades y automáticamente las asignó
como asigno cualquier otro contenido
entonces aquí yo pongo a qué clase
quiero asignar las a que estudiantes
quiero asignar las que recuerden que en
este caso tenemos que asignarlo a todos
voy a poner la fecha de entrega digamos
y la hora en que quiero que estas
actividades estén terminadas y la hago
clic en en el motor de botón de asignar
para que automáticamente se asigne a mi
clase entonces siempre desde
mis cursos ahí voy a encontrar
mentalidad de crecimiento también si me
desplazo aquí mismo encuentro las
actividades de bachillerato entonces
según sea mi caso voy a seleccionar las
de primaria de secundaria o las de
bachillerato entonces recuerda nada más
hago clic selecciono
y asignó alguna pregunta les voy a
agradecer mucho que por favor si tienen
alguna pregunta de cómo encontré el
contenido de mentalidad de crecimiento
como lo asigne me lo hagan saber aquí a
través del chat con mucho gusto vuelvo a
repasar esta parte porque es muy
importante que todos entendamos dónde
están estas mentalidades estas
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
y como las pueda asignar así que si
alguien tiene alguna duda por favor
hagamos sabe por chat y con mucho gusto
volvemos a repasar esta parte
nos comenta jose el profesor josé franco
en irapuato premio con 30% más de
calificación por parcial a los alumnos
que llegan a la meta que les impongo
además de darles un reconocimiento en
cada acto cívico que se realiza en el
plantel el profesor josé franco lo
felicito me parece una excelente manera
de reconocer a los alumnos no a través
de las calificaciones finales y nosotros
asignamos un porcentaje de nuestra
calificación final al trabajo que se
hace en la plataforma de khan academy
los alumnos automáticamente están
motivados porque khan academy eso es
algo fácil para ellos es una especie
como de su tutor personal no entonces no
hay manera de que fracasen en esto no en
la medida que ellos practican y
practican y practican van logrando no
dominar más conceptos entonces
si esto se los cuentan para sus
calificaciones eso automáticamente los
motiva así que es una excelente manera
de hacerlo
rosa
a rosa me me dicen nosotros festejamos
con un vaso de leche y un panqueque
lo que ellos hacen en su casa bueno otra
manera excelente y de verdad gracias por
sus sugerencias porque como ven esto nos
va enriqueciendo a todos no porque todos
podemos aprender de las experiencias de
otros así que de verdad agradezco las
sugerencias o sea me parece increíble no
que los mismos alumnos hagan
un panqué y lo compartan con los alumnos
sobre todo con aquellos que lograron sus
objetivos bueno me parece de verdad algo
es muy lindo no muy muy título de
comentar ya lo mejor no te dé también
copiar no es a esa estrategia
bueno nuevamente aquí en la presentación
ustedes también tienen los pasos de cómo
encontrarlos dentro de contenidos las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
recuerden que en sus cursos en la parte
de hasta abajo van a encontrar aquí las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
una vez que las asignan las guardan
cuando se vayan a contenido siempre van
a aparecer ahí las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento
y una vez que ya las tienen guardadas
que ya las tienen parte de su curso ya
nada más les toca a ustedes seleccionar
cuáles son esas actividades y ya están
de primaria del secundario de
bachillerato que son las que quieren
asignar es así de sencillo
entonces si no tienen alguna duda con
respecto a eso vamos a seguir adelante
si tienen alguna duda de cómo localizar
estas actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento nuevamente hágamelo saber y
con gusto repasamos esta información
es muy importante que nos registremos ya
a campeonato si no lo han hecho si es la
primera vez que entran a un webinar no
de capacitación de khan academy los
invitamos a que se registren ya no en
campeonato punto a cada punto org pueden
hacerlo pueden encontrar más información
y yo creo que esta frase no que promueve
khan academy me parece muy importante al
principio nadie es bueno en alguna cosa
afortunadamente nacimos para aprender y
es algo muy cierto no nada nadie nació
aprendiendo nada nada no todo y nosotros
no nosotros somos un cierto fieles
testigos de eso no porque ahorita
también como docentes tenemos muchos
retos
la educación cambia día a día la
tecnología cambia día a día tenemos que
estar constantemente actualizando nos
constantemente aprendiendo
y para eso nacimos para seguir
aprendiendo para seguir mejorando no
y rosa me comenta también en la
institución se califica con rúbricas y
se les da también un 30% felicidades
a los de con los reconocimientos cuando
nos van a llegar estos van a llegar una
vez que termine el programa por ese
campeonato dura 10 semanas estoy tenemos
un largo camino por adelante por lo que
tenemos que que cumplir que cumplir con
éxito entonces ahorita el objetivo y
donde tenemos que enfocar toda nuestra
energía es en motivar a nuestros alumnos
no a que tengan éxito a que alcancen
también el éxito a nivel grupal no a que
todos contestan sus actividades a
promover esta mentalidad de crecimiento
de manera que podamos también compartir
nosotros no estas historias de éxito yo
de verdad los quiero invitar es es muy
importante para nuestros planteles para
nuestro país para ustedes para nuestros
alumnos el que compartan sus historias
tanto la mentalidad de crecimiento como
de éxito en campeonato no usen el
hashtag campeonato 2018 o simplemente el
hashtag campeonato en cualquier resto
que tengas no se manejan twitter entren
a twitter suban un vídeo no sé si sus
alumnos están pendientes del tablero de
progreso y están celebrando no el que
llegaron al nivel 6 el que lograron el
éxito el que lograron el 100 por ciento
tomar es un vídeo con tú con tu celular
un vídeo corto que pueda subir después a
una red
no puedes
poner a usar el hashtag decir mi mitad
al grupo del conalep puedo de x lugar de
x plantel este logró su objetivo
felicidades grupo y todo esto de verdad
motiva aún más a los alumnos no porque
ya el reconocimiento es externo no es es
muy público también lo pueden hacer en
facebook
en facebook existe una página que es
khan academy en español que los quiero
invitar a que la sigan si ustedes están
en la presentación pueden hacer clic
aquí en el enlace khan academy en
español y los va a llevar directamente a
la plataforma de facebook y a la página
de khan academy en español y aquí por
ejemplo les estoy abriendo yo la página
yo les aconsejo que la sigan ghana
cambien español constantemente está
subiendo información vídeos
capacitaciones entrenamientos entonces
es una plataforma bueno perdón es una
página que nos enriquece mucho nuestra
labor como docentes entonces la
encuentran en facebook sígala y ahí
mismo pueden ustedes postear sus
historias de éxito o sus experiencias
con las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento etcétera
regresando a la presentación
no se olviden entonces de subir fotos
vídeos experiencias consejos sugerencias
a estas redes sociales pueden hacerlo
nuevamente con este hashtag tanto en
facebook como en twitter como instagram
si tienen las tres redes sociales
excelentes sino la que sea que manejen
los invitamos a que la usen o para
compartir con todos estos historias de
éxito
y pues bueno está
capacitación está llegando a su fin
quiero pedirles de favor que se tomen un
par de minutos es muy importante esta
parte
para que complete en esta pequeña
evaluación esta pequeña encuesta si
ustedes están ahorita dentro de la
presentación les voy a pedir que hagan
nada más clic en el enlace para que se
abra el formulario y me lo complete por
favor si no tienen audita a su
dispositivo a la mano les voy a pedir
así de manera bueno de verdad se lo voy
a agradecer mucho si toman una foto al
enlace y ya después con calma en casita
en o cuando tengan un tiempo completo en
este formulario esta encuesta no les va
a tomar les prometo que más de cinco
minutos mucho menos que eso sin embargo
para nosotros es muy importante porque
nos nos permite mejorar nos permite
realmente atender las necesidades de
cada uno de ustedes saber además quién
quien participó en la capacitación quien
entró etcétera llevar un poquito el
registro de quienes están participando
pero sobre todo de cómo nosotros podemos
atender mejor las necesidades y resolver
las dudas que ustedes tengan entonces
les voy
a pedir que en los dos minutos tres
minutos que nos quedan de esta
capacitación se den ese tiempo para
completar este formulario
desgraciadamente no puedo el profesor
hair desgraciadamente no puedo poner el
enlace porque no me permite pero es kg
punto g diagonal de de bueno t de tomás
4 r w y nuevamente pueden tomar una foto
pueden
este en anotar un papelito lo que pasa
es que al ponerlo en el chat me lo
rechaza ya lo intente antes con el
enlace de la presentación y bueno por mi
parte es todo les agradezco muchísimo a
su atención pero sobre todo su
compromiso con con este proyecto y la
verdad es que su devoción por como
docentes no agradezco mucho todo el
trabajo que ustedes hacen y reconozco de
verdad esta maravillosa labor que hacen
en cada uno de sus planteles
por mi parte es todo les agradezco
nuevamente y les deseo que tengan una
excelente excelente semana
gracias a todos